hey what's up Samuel leaves here and in
this video I want to give you the tools
and information and equip you ready to
buy your first property investment the
very first thing you need to know when
viewing a property is what is the true
current market value what that means is
how much is the house actually worth
most people get distracted by the asking
price but the asking price is completely
irrelevant
the asking price could be a million
pounds and the house could be worth
nothing so doesn't matter what the
asking price is it matters what the true
current not what was the value five
years ago what is the true current
market value you need to know that next
number two is you need to know what is
the lowest that they can accept and
still live with how do you find the
answer to this question ask them every
time I do a viewing I always ask the
question I set I decide if I was to buy
this cash tomorrow what would be the
lowest that you could accept and still
live with and then I shut up and wait
for them to respond no is it's an if
would if I was to buy cash tomorrow
saying I can if what would be almost
speaking hypothetically what would be
the lowest that you could accept and
still live with get their answer so now
you know the true current market value
and you know what they will accept
tomorrow should you buy a fast for cash
tomorrow number three what is the true
market rent in other words when you buy
this property what will he went out for
and not what did the estate agent say to
you it would read out for not what did
the deal packager that's trying to sell
you the deal tell you that it will rent
out for how much will this property
actually rent out for you need to know
that figure number four you need to know
how are you going to finance the deal
what's the plan are you gonna are you
gonna buy cash are you gonna get a
mortgage on the property and put down a
deposit if so have you gotten the
deposit can you get the finance can you
get a mortgage on the property are you
gonna be doing a joint venture you're
gonna someone else to be put in the cash
in if so are they ready to put the cash
down tomorrow
what's your finance plan are you gonna
have to refinance it later wanna see you
added
to it you need to know your numbers and
you need to know the finances and how
you're gonna find that's the property
and is that realistic number five does
the house need work doing to it and if
so how much sometimes you can miss stuff
because they can be damp and they've
titled over the damp and you need to
know how much work needs do into a
property if the roof is bad how much is
it going to cost to fix it you need to
know this sort of stuff and you don't
need to be an expert builder yourself
but you need to send someone to the
property before you buy who is number
six what is your vision for the property
what's your plan don't just buy a house
because you like it I feels nice this
can't be about feelings he's asking me
about formulas don't buy a house because
you just think and one day I might be
able to live in as a holiday home and or
it's close to my son's university who
cares who cares is close to your son's
university geez what's the vision as a
property investment for the property is
it going to be a bike select property
where you're just gonna buy it and rent
it out if so what's the return on
investment is that good I don't buy a
property unless the return on investment
is at least 20 percent if you're gonna
be buying it are you find it to do it as
I do up and sell are you buying it to do
it off and then refinance it and rent it
out are you splitting it into apartments
is it going to be a hmm is it going to
be a student accommodation what's your
vision for the property and does it make
sense is it logical and then lastly
number seven is what are the risks
associated with buying the property and
do you have an exit strategy
so whenever I make any decision whether
it being a decision to attend a training
program to invest in a person of
business to buy a house any decision I'm
always gonna look at what's the best
case what's the worst case and what's
the likely case and the worst case how
feasible is that what's my exit plan
would that [ __ ] me financially if the
answer is yeah only financially and that
could happen and I've got no exit plan
to escape the wrath of the situation if
it happens then I'm out so what is the
worst that could happen and then you've
got a risk assess the deal all of these
things these seven things that you need
to know in buying a property down to
valuing the house valuing the rents
having an exit strategy knowing your
numbers all this stuff you can learn for
free with me for two days at the
property investors crash course people
come from all over the
world to this program and we always sell
the program out weeks sometimes months
in advance so my suggestion to you if
you're serious about making money in
property is come and spend two days with
me for free on the house at the property
investors crash course there's a link
below what is your excuse
get booked right now
[Music]
[Music]